I just spent five minutes cleaning off
this desk give you the fake illusion
that I am tidy no there's just a bunch
of [ __ ] on the floor now
hello yep very appealing to a wide
variety of people
hello I have hair and makeup leftover
from an earlier photoshoot and I'm also
wearing a burqa tank top which can only
mean one thing time to judge other
people's fashion choices the MTV Movie
Awards happened yesterday Sunday and a
lot of people went to it
dressed in things made up with paints
and lotions and jill's and products what
I've come to realize is that award shows
are just lotion conventions - let's
review the MTV Movie Award fashion
Scarlett Johansson she looks like a very
elegant Laffy Taffy that's a very big
compliment in my opinion is it delicious
candy it gets stuck in the crevices of
all of your teeth and you hate it for a
brief moment in time but the next time
someone is like hey I have a Laffy Taffy
do you want one you're like yes of
course I remember zero consequences of
this candy JLo
JLo more like Jayco trying age for a
second you look beautiful
I've also noticed recently that inner
boob is very popular side boob tacky it
seems like you fly girl hey shout-out to
her past Amy Schumer who was the host of
the MTV Movie Awards looks great and is
on that inner boob train 100% I love
this dress I feel like if your dog
somehow met up with a genie wizard witch
doctor type of person and gained the
ability to talk you could actually have
a conversation with your dog about this
dress because they would also know a
color it was hard alpha Shannon ayer
keroh Delphine Countdown's with Kara
Alvah Shondell Vitara duh but the model
girl that is just so cool cara cara is
I'm sorry that I pronounced it wrong
goes to err is human that shudder car is
a hugely famous supermodel and is also
the star of the new movie Paper Towns
based on a novel written by John Green
figure out why this physicality happened
if you don't know you should know if you
don't know what but let's get to the
most important thing the fashion she
looks great Victoria Justice looks like
80s aerobics instructor was like I'm
going to a formal event but I don't want
to lose my brand shailene woodley who
was the star of the film The Fault in
Our Stars written by John Green Jenny
just has such predictable pattern
behavior patterns that's go away
jug's grey she looks like she was at
Coachella shooting an ad for H&M and
then she was like oh Sh I forgot about
them TV movie Awards I need to go now
I'll wear this this girl whose name I
completely forget but looks so sad why
do you look so sad willow shields aka
Primrose Everdeen from The Hunger Games
looks very prim and proper I will call
this style
oops I'm an adult because that's what
this pose says to me like oops
I grew up deal with it that or she just
knows that she has an audible fart on
deck and is really making attempts to
shut it down both situations very adult
Charli XCX this is the juxtaposition of
how fun her dress looks versus
her facial why so sad angry sexy Lilly
Singh iisuperwomanii was on the red
carpet or blue carpet what empty beach
quirky I texted her tonight because I
thought I I really loved her outfit I
was like you look great you have fun you
look cool you don't you're trying too
hard and you look like yourself and that
cool way to represent the fact that
internet people are clean sometimes John
Green so let's say that that well there
you go that was my brief review
conversation about the MTV Movie Award
fashions
I hope they enjoyed this video if you
did let us do this digitally leave a
comment down below what you thought of
the fashions and subscribe so that you
don't have to work to see these videos I
don't know now stop her get her stop
looking at me there she is Miss Merck ah